sie arbeiten hier illegal und ohne
schutz um mich zu hungern es ist stickig
es ist heiß und die wände könnten
jederzeit einstürzen und es sind nicht
nur erwachsene die hier arbeiten sondern
auch kinder
das sind bilder aus indien das ist über
7000 kilometer weit weg und trotzdem hat
es was mit uns zu tun
es ist die dunkle seite davon was unsere
schön schimmern lässt das klima material
mika ist ein wichtiger rohstoff für
richtig viele kosmetikprodukte es ist
highlight der lippenstift und nagellack
so schön funkeln wie kann es jetzt sein
dass kinder den preis dafür zahlen und
was wird dagegen getan
[Musik]
macht ihr das gerne sie sind zwischen 6
und 8 und sie sammeln sonntags micra in
einem der ärmsten staaten indiens in
jack ahnt dass es illegal aber sie sind
bei weitem nicht allein der saison
schätzt dass circa 22.000 kinder in
indien mika schärfen statt in die schule
zu gehen den meisten konzernen jetzt
diesen rohstoff verwendeten von chemie
über kosmetik bis hin zu autoherstellern
ist das problem bekannt
sie wollen auch etwas tun doch eine
wirkliche lösung ist nicht in sicht das
klima material kommt auf der ganzen welt
vor aber etwa 30 prozent des klimas der
nach europa kommt stammt aus indien und
zwar zu 90 prozent aus einem teil in dem
der rohstoff offiziell gar nicht
abgebaut werden darf markant und bihar
gehören zu den ärmsten regionen indiens
und genau hier liegt der klimagipfel
seit 1980 ist dort der abbau aus
naturschutzgründen zwar offiziell
verboten
geht aber trotzdem weiter den micra ist
dort quasi die einzige möglichkeit geld
übergeben
[Musik]
jetzt läuft der abbau in der region
komplett illegal in hunderten kleinen
stollen
dort arbeiten dann ganze familien sie
springen sich teilweise in den berg oder
sammle mika an der oberfläche und die
arbeit ist gefährlich der staub macht
krank und immer wieder brechen stollen
ein es kommt zu schweren verletzungen
und zu todesfällen in der region
bezahlen pro monat etwa zwölf menschen
den job mit ihrem leben anita de hat bei
einem grubenunglück ihren mann verloren
seither mussten vier kinder allein
versorgen
[Musik]
anna lang sowohl der abbau als auch
kinderarbeit in minen sind offiziell
verboten aber die kontrollen strecke
nicht möglich ab damit dass mika dann
international verkauft werden kann wann
das durch diverse zwischenhändler an
erster stelle stehen die kleinen
sammelstellen und danach verwischen auch
recht schnell die spuren zwischenhändler
kaufen sich offizielle zertifikate wie
dieses hier um das mikro reinzuwaschen
dann stammt der rohstoff offiziell aus
legalen in rajasthan und ist zu 100
prozent ohne kinderarbeit abgebaut
worden so ist es dann bereits im export
denn viele große unternehmen auch in
europa bestehen eben auf diesen
offiziellen zertifikaten die kosten zwar
aber das geschäft ist lukrativ genug das
alles ist seit jahren bekannt spätestens
jedoch seit 2000 16 da gab es diverse
bericht über die zustände vor ort und
zeit hat sich zwar ein bisschen was
getan
das problem allerdings bleibt die
indische regierung hat 2017 sogar
angekündigt den abbau zu legalisieren
damit man ihn besser kontrollieren kann
geschehen ist bisher aber nicht viel
eine traurige folge der berichte ist
dass die geschäfte teilweise jetzt noch
stärker vertuscht werden und dass
unfälle noch seltener gemeldet werden
aus angst vor konsequenzen aber
gleichzeitig hat die berichterstattung
auch den druck auf viele konzerne erhöht
etwa 5
die konzerne haben sich seit 2017 zu
einer ngo zusammengeschlossen die die
kinderarbeit bis 2022 auslöschen will
auch durch konsequente nachverfolgung
die unternehmen wissen jetzt also das
aktuell kinder für den rohstoff arbeiten
der import stoppen sollen sie laut der
ngo aber nicht
im ausland ist die post ein fertiges
gewisse courage
das wird also dauern denn dafür braucht
es einen strukturwandel in der region
und bis dahin wie gut lassen sich die
lieferanten überhaupt kontrollieren
der chemieriese merck zum beispiel
gehört zu den größten abnehmern und
betont es gebe null toleranz gegen
welchen bearbeitet dafür würden eigene
kontrollen sorgen in der realität lässt
sich das jedoch kaum garantieren und
sieht wohl auch so aus das beispiel
zeigt mal wieder wie schwierig ist den
konzern fällt ihre weltweiten und
verschachtelten lieferketten zu
kontrollieren
zudem verlassen sich viele unternehmen
nach wie vor auf die staatlichen
zertifikate und kontrolle von denen wir
jetzt wissen dass sie oft auch nicht
standhalten und deshalb ist jetzt auch
die frage was können wir verbraucher tun
und die ist leider gar nicht so einfach
zu beantworten denn mika ist in so
vielen produkten dass wir es gar nicht
wirklich vermeiden können wenn ich durch
meine alltäglichen kosmetikprodukte gier
ist mika in fast allen produkten drin
deklariert wird es entweder als micra
oder als
770 19 schaut mal bei euch in den sachen
war
und 12 und das sind dann auch nur die
kosmetikprodukte daneben ist es in
autolack und in ganz vielen
elektronikprodukten und weil die
lieferwege so undurchsichtig sind ist es
für uns verbraucher fast unmöglich
herauszufinden ob kinderarbeit in den
produkten steckt was man jetzt also tun
terre des hommes empfiehlt drei dinge
wir können auf jeden fall nachfragen
sowohl bei den unternehmen als auch bei
den herstellern und damit das
bewusstsein und den druck erhöhen und
dafür sorgen dass die mehr transparenz
bieten und auch einfordern
außerdem gibt es organisationen die sich
vor ort gegen kinderarbeit engagieren
die kann man natürlich auch unterstützen
oder man kann sich dafür einsetzen dass
zum beispiel die deutsche regierung
dafür sorgt dass unternehmen mehr
verantwortung entlang der lieferkette
übernehmen müssen und es nicht nur in
ihren broschüren und auf der homepage
steht aber was auch klar ist solange die
zwischenhändler vor ort damit so gutes
geschäft machen und die menschen vor
keine alternativen haben wird sich
vermutlich auch nicht so schnell was
ändern komplett transparente
lieferketten sind aktuell utopisch und
so müssen sich entlang der ganzen
produktion von der mine bis hin zu uns
verbrauchern alle der verantwortung
bewusst sein es könnten immer kinder an
den produkten gearbeitet haben
[Musik]
schön dass die zugeschaut hat und sogar
nach dem dschungel noch da sein bei so
viel motivation würde ich mich freuen
wenn ihr mal unten in die kommentare
schreiben
mit welchen themen wir uns dieses jahr
noch beschäftigen sollten